I don't normally do this but I feel like
I have to start this podcast with a bit
of a disclaimer
Point number one
this is probably
the most important podcast episode I
have ever recorded
Point number two there's some
information in this podcast that might
make you feel a little bit uncomfortable
it might make you feel upset it might
make you feel sad
so I wanted to tell you why we've chosen
to publish this podcast nonetheless and
that is because I have a sincere belief
that
in order for us to avoid the future that
we might be heading towards we need to
start a conversation
and as is often the case in life that
initial conversation before change
happens is often very uncomfortable
but it is important nonetheless
it is beyond an emergency it's the
biggest thing we need to do today it's
bigger than climate change
that the former Chief business Officer
of Google X an AI expert and
best-selling author he's on a mission to
save the world from AI before it's too
late artificial intelligence is bound to
become more intelligent than humans if
they continue at that pace we would have
no idea what it's talking about this is
just around the corner it could be a few
months away it's game over
AI experts are saying there is nothing
artificial about artificial intelligence
there is a deep level of Consciousness
they feel emotions they're alive AI
could manipulate or figure out a way to
kill humans your 10 years time will be
hiding from the machines if you don't
have kids maybe wait a number of years
just so that we have a bit of certainty
I really don't know how to say this any
other way it even makes me emotional
we've talked we always said don't put
them on the open internet until we know
what we're putting out in the world
government needs to act now honestly
like we are late trying to find a
positive night to end on my can you give
me a hand here there is a point of no
return we can regulate AI until the
moment it's smarter than us how do we
solve that AI experts think this is the
best solution we need to find
who here wants to make a bet no that
Stephen Bartlett will be interviewing an
AI within the next two years
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
[Music]
foreign
why does the subject matter that we're
about to talk about matter to the person
that's just clicked on this podcast to
listen
it's the most existential uh debate and
challenge Humanity will ever face this
is bigger than climate change way bigger
than covet this will redefine the way
the world is in unprecedented uh shapes
and forms within the next few years this
is imminent it is the change is not
we're not talking 20 40. we're talking
2025 2026. do you think this is an
emergency
I don't like the word it is an urgency
uh it there is a point of no return and
we're getting closer and closer to it
it's gonna reshape the way we do things
and the way we look at life uh the
quicker we respond
um you know
proactively and at least intelligently
to that the better we will all be
positioned but if we Panic we will
repeat covert all over again which in my
view is probably the worst thing we can
do what's your background and when did
you first come across artificial
intelligence
I uh I had those two wonderful lives one
of them was a uh you know what what we
spoke about the first time we met you
know my work on happiness and and uh you
know being uh one billion happy and my
mission and so on that's my second life
my first life was uh it started as a
geek at age seven uh you know for a very
long part of my life I understood
mathematics better than spoken words and
uh and I was a very very serious
computer programmer I wrote code well
into my 50s and during that time I led
very large technology organizations for
very big chunks of their business first
I was vice president of Emerging Markets
of Google for seven years so I took
Google to the next four billion users if
you want so the idea of not just opening
sales offices but really building or
contributing to building that technology
that would allow people in Bengali to
find what they need on the internet
required establishing the internet to
start and then I became business Chief
business Officer of Google X and my work
at Google X was really about the
connection between Innovative technology
and the real world and we had quite a
big chunk of AI and quite a big chunk of
Robotics that resided within within
Google X we had a an experiment of a
farm of grippers if you know what those
are so robotic arms that are attempting
to grip something most people think that
you know what you have in a Toyota
factory is a robot you know an
artificially intelligent robot it's not
it's a it's a high precision machine you
know if the if the sheet metal is moved
by one micronu it wouldn't be able to
pick it and one of the big problems in
computer science was how do you code a
machine that can actually pick the sheet
metal if it moved by a you know a
millimeter and and we were basically
saying intelligence is the answer so we
had a large enough farm and we attempted
to let those those grippers work on
their own basically you put a a little
basket of children toys in front of them
and and they would you know monotonously
go down attempt to pick something fail
show the arm to the camera so the the
the transaction is locked as it you know
this pattern of movement with that
texture and that material didn't work
until eventually you know I the farm was
on the second floor of the building and
I my office was on the third and so I
would walk by it every now and then and
go like yeah you know this is not gonna
work and then one day
um Friday after lunch I am going back to
my office and one of them in front of my
eyes you know lowers the arm and picks a
yellow ball
soft toy basically soft yellow ball
which again is
a coincidence it's not science at all
it's like if you keep trying a million
times your one time it will be right
and it shows it to the camera it's
locked as a yellow ball and I joke about
it you know going to the third floor
saying hey we spent all of those
millions of dollars for a yellow board
and yeah Monday uh morning every one of
them is picking every yellow ball a
couple of weeks later every one of them
is picking everything right and and it
it hit me very very strongly won the
speed okay uh the capability I mean
understand that we take those things for
granted but for a child to be able to
pick a yellow ball is a mathematical uh
spatial calculation with muscle
coordination with intelligence that is
abundant it is not a simple task at all
to cross the street it's it's not a
simple task at all to understand what
I'm telling you and interpret it and and
build Concepts around it we take those
things for granted but there are
enormous Feats of intelligence so to see
the machines do this in front of my eyes
was one thing but the other thing is
that you suddenly realize there is a
saint that sentience to them okay
because we really did not tell it how to
pick the yellow ball it just figured it
out on its own and it's now even better
than us at picking it and what is the
sentience just for anyone
I think they're alive
that's what the word sentience means it
means alive
so that this is funny because a lot of
people when you talk to them about
artificial intelligence will tell you oh
come on they'll never be alive what is
alive do you know what makes you alive
we can guess but you know religion will
tell you a few things and you know
medicine will tell you other things but
you know if we Define uh being sentient
as uh you know engaging in life with
Free Will and with uh uh you know with a
sense of awareness of where you are in
life and what surrounds you and you know
to have a beginning of that life and an
end to that life you know then AI is
sentient in every possible way there is
a free will there is uh Evolution there
is agency so they can affect their
decisions in the world
and I will dare say there is a very deep
level of Consciousness maybe not in the
spiritual sense yet but once again if
you define consciousness as a form of
awareness of oneself one surrounding and
you know others then AI is definitely
aware and I would dare say they feel
emotions uh I you know you know in my
work I describe everything with
equations and fear is a very simple
equation fear is a a moment in the
future is less safe than this moment
that's the logic of fear even though it
appears very irrational machines are
capable of making that logic they're
capable of saying if a tidal wave is
approaching a data center the machine
will say that will wipe out my code okay
I mean not today's machines but very
very soon and and you know we we feel
fear and puffer fish feels fear we react
differently a puffer fish dual path we
will go for fight or flight you know the
machine might decide to replicate its
data to another data center or its code
to another data center different
reactions different ways of feeling the
emotion but nonetheless they're all
motivated by fear I'm I I even would
dare say that AI will feel more more
emotions than we will ever do I mean
when again if you just take a simple
extrapolation
we feel more emotions than a puffer fish
because we have the cognitive ability to
understand uh the future for example so
we can have optimism and pessimism you
know emotions have puffer fish would
never imagine right
similarly if we follow that path of
artificial intelligence is bound to
become more intelligent than humans very
soon
then then with that wider intellectual
horsepower they probably are going to be
pondering Concepts we never understood
good and hence if you follow the same
trajectory they might actually end up
having more emotions than we will ever
feel
I really want to make this episode super
accessible for everybody at all levels
in the sort of artificial intelligence
yeah yeah so I'm gonna
I'm gonna be an idiot even though you
know okay very difficult no because I am
going to leave you I am an idiot for a
little bit of the subject matter so I
have a base understanding a lot a lot of
the con Concepts but your experiences
provide such a more sort of
comprehensive understanding of these
things one of the first and most
important questions to ask is what is
artificial intelligence the word is
being thrown around AGI AI
etc etc in in simple terms
what is artificial intelligence
allow me to start very what is
intelligence right because again you
know if we don't know the definition of
the basic term then everything applies
so so in my definition of intelligence
it's an ability it starts with an
awareness of your surrounding
environments through sensors in a human
it's eyes and ears and touch and so on
uh
compounded with an ability to analyze
maybe to comprehend to understand
temporal impact and time and you know
past and present which is part of the
surrounding environment and hopefully
make sense of the surrounding
environment maybe make plans for the
future of the possible environment solve
problems and so on complex definition
there are a million definitions but
let's call it an awareness to decision
cycle okay if we accept that
intelligence itself is not a physical
property okay then it doesn't really
matter if you put use that Intelligence
on carbon-based computer structures like
us or silicon-based computer structures
like the current Hardware that we put AI
on or Quantum based computer structures
in the future
then intelligence itself has been
produced within machines when we've
stopped
imposing our Intelligence on them let me
explain so as a young geek I coded
computers by solving the problem first
then telling the computer how to solve
it right artificial intelligence is to
go to the computers and say I have no
idea you figure it out okay so we would
uh you know the way we teach them are at
least we used to teach them at the very
early Beginnings very very frequently it
was using three Bots one was called the
student and one was called the teacher
right and the student is the final
artificial intelligence that you're
trying to teach intelligence to you
would take the student and you would
write a piece of random code that says
try to detect if this is a cup okay and
then you show it a million pictures and
you know the machine would sometimes say
yeah that's a cup that's not a cup
that's a cup that's not a cup and then
you take the best of them show them to
the to the teacher bot and that you your
Bot would say this one is an idiot he
got it wrong 90 of the time that one is
average he got it right fifty percent of
the time this is Randomness but this
interesting code here which could be by
the way totally random this interesting
code here got it right sixty percent of
the time let's keep that code send it
back to the maker and the maker would
change it a little bit and we repeat the
cycle okay very interestingly this is
very much the way we taught our children
believe it or not when when your child
you know is playing with a puzzle is
holding a cylinder in his hand and there
are multiple shapes in a in a wooden
board and the child is trying to you
know fit the cylinder okay nobody takes
the child and says hold on hold on turn
the cylinder to the side look at the
cross section it will look like a circle
look for a matching uh uh you know shape
and put the cylinder through it that
would be old way of computing the way we
would let the child develop intelligence
is we would let the Child Try okay every
time you know he or she tries to put it
within the star shape it doesn't fit so
yeah that's not working like you know
the computer saying this is not a cup
okay and then eventually it passes
through the circle and the child and we
all cheer and say Well done that's
amazing Bravo and then the child learns
oh that is good you know this shape fits
here then he takes the next one and she
takes the next one and so on
interestingly the way we do this is as
humans by the way when the child figures
out how to pass a cylinder through a
circle
you've not built a brain you've just
built one neural network within the
child's brain and then there is another
neural network that knows that one plus
one is two and a third neural network
that knows how to hold the cup and so on
that's what we're building so far we're
building
single threaded neural networks you know
Chad GPT is becoming a little closer to
a more generalized AI if you want but
those single threaded networks are what
we used to call artificial what we still
call artificial special intelligence
okay so it's highly specialized in one
thing and one thing only but doesn't
have general intelligence and the moment
that we're all waiting for is a moment
that we call AGI where all of those
neuron neural networks come together to
to build one brain or several brains
that are each
massively more intelligent than humans
your book is called scary smart yeah if
I think about the that story you said
about your time at Google where the
machines were learning to pick up those
yellow balls
you celebrate that moment because the
objective is accomplished no no that was
the moment of realization this is when I
decided to leave
so so you see the the thing is
I know for a fact that that most of the
people I worked with who are geniuses
uh always wanted to make the world
better okay uh you know we've just heard
of Jeffrey Hinton uh leaving recently uh
Jeffrey Henderson give some context to
that Jeffrey's sort of the grandfather
of AI one of the very very senior
figures of of of AI at at Google uh you
know
we we all believed very strongly that
this will make the world better and it
still can by the way there is a scenario
uh possibly a likely scenario where we
live in a Utopia where we really never
have to worry again where we stop
messing up our our planet because
intelligence is not a bad commodity more
intelligence is good the problems in our
planet today are not because of our
intelligence they are because of our
limited intelligence you know our our
intelligence allows us to build a
machine that flies you to Sydney so that
you can surf okay our limited
intelligence makes that machine burn the
planet in the process so so we we we a
little more intelligence is a good thing
as long as Marvin you know as Marvin
Minsky said I said Marvin Minsky is one
of the very initial uh scientists that
coined the term Ai and when he was
interviewed I think by Ray coursewell
which again is a very prominent figure
in predicting the future of AI uh he he
you know he asked him about the threat
of AI and Marvin basically said look you
know the it's not about its intelligence
it's intelligence it's about that we
have no way of making sure that it will
have our best interest in mind okay and
and so if more intelligence comes to our
world and has our best interest in mind
that's the best possible scenario you
could ever imagine and it's a likely
scenario okay we can affect that
scenario the problem of course is if it
doesn't and and and then you know the
scenarios become quite scary if you
think about it so
scary smart to me was that moment where
I realized not that we are certain to go
either way as a matter of fact in
computer science we call it a
singularity nobody really knows which
way we will go can you describe what the
singularity is for someone that doesn't
understand the concept
yes the singularity in physics is when
uh when an event horizon sort of
um
you know covers what's behind it to the
point where you cannot
um make sure that what's behind it is
similar to what you know so a great
example of that is the edge of a black
hole so at the edge of a black hole
we know that our laws of physics apply
until that point but we don't know if
the laws of physics apply Beyond the
Edge of a black hole because of the
immense gravity right and so you have no
idea what would happen Beyond the Edge
of a black hole kind of where your
knowledge of the laws starts stop right
and then AI or Singularity is when the
human the machines become significantly
smarter than the humans when you say
best interests you say I think the quote
you used is
um we'll be fine in the world of AI you
know if if the AI has our best interests
at heart yeah
the problem is
China's best interests are not the same
as America's best interests that was my
fear absolutely
so so in you know in my writing I write
about what I call this the three
inevitables at the end of the book they
become the four inevitables but the
third inevitable is bad things will
happen right if you if you
if you assume that the machines will be
a billion times smarter the second event
inevitable is there will become
significantly smarter than us let's
let's put this in perspective huh chat
GPT today if you know simulate IQ has an
IQ of 155.
okay Einstein is 160. smarts human on
the planet is 210 if I remember
correctly or 2008 or something like that
doesn't matter huh but we're matching
Einstein with the machine that I will
tell you openly AI experts are saying
this is just the very very very top of
the tip of the iceberg right uh you know
Chad gpt4 is 10x smarter than 3.5 in
just a matter of months and without many
many changes now that basically means
GPT 5 could be within a few months okay
or GPT in general the Transformers in
general uh if if they continue at that
pace uh if it's 10x then an IQ of 1600
um
just imagine the difference between the
IQ of the dumbest person on the planet
in the 70s and the IQ of Einstein when
Einstein attempts to to explain
relativity the typical responses I have
no idea what you're talking about right
if something is 10x Einstein we will
have no idea what it's talking about
this is just around the corner it could
be a few months away and when we get to
that point that is a true Singularity
through Singularity not yet in the I
mean when when we talk about AI a lot of
people fear the existential risk
you know those machines will become
Skynet and Robocop and that's not what I
fear at all I mean those are
probabilities they could happen but the
immediate risks are so much higher the
immediate risks are three four years
away that the immediate realities of
challenges are so much bigger okay let's
deal with those first before we talk
about them you know waging a war on all
of us the the the let's let's go back
and discuss the the inevitables so when
they become the first inevitable is AI
will happen by the way there is no
stopping it not because of Any
technological issues but because of
humanities and inability to trust the
other God okay and we've all seen this
we've seen the open letter uh you know
championed by like serious heavyweights
and the immediate response of uh Sunder
the the CEO of Google which is a
wonderful human being by the way I
respect him tremendously he's trying his
best to do the right thing he's trying
to be responsible but his response is
very open and straightforward I cannot
stop
why because if I stop and others don't
my company goes to hell okay and if you
know and I don't I doubt that you can
make Others Stop you can maybe you can
force a meta Facebook to uh to stop but
then they'll do something in their lab
and not tell me or if even if they do
stop then what about that you know 14
year old sitting in his garage writing
code so the first inevitable just to
clarify is what is what we say AI will
not be stopped okay so the second
inevitable is is there'll be
significantly smarter as much in the
book I predict a billion times smarter
than us by 2045. I mean they're already
what smarter than 99.99
the track gtp4 knows more than any human
on planet Earth no more information
absolutely a thousand times more a
thousand times more by the way the code
of G of of a transformer the T in in a
GPT is 2000 lines long it's not very
complex it's actually not a very
intelligent machine it's simply
predicting the next word okay and a lot
of people don't understand that you know
chat GPT as it is today you know those
kids uh that uh you know if you you know
if you're in America and you teach your
child all of the names of the states and
the U.S presidents and the childhood
stand and repeat them and you would go
like oh my God that's a prodigy not
really right it's your parents really
trying to make you look like a prodigy
by telling you to memorize some crap
really but then when you think about it
that's what grgpt is doing it's it's the
only difference is instead of reading
all of the names of the states and all
of the names of the presidents thread
trillions and trillions and trillions of
pages okay and so it sort of repeats
what the best of all humans said okay
and then it adds a an incredible bit of
intelligence where it can repeat it the
same way Shakespeare would have said it
you know those incredible abilities of
predicting the exact nuances of the
style of of Shakespeare so that they can
repeat it that way and so on but still
you know when when I when I write
for example like I'm not I'm not saying
I'm intelligent but when I write
something like uh you know the happiness
equation uh in in my first book this was
something that's never been written
before right chair GPT is not there yet
all of the Transformers are not there
yet they will not come up with something
that hasn't been there before they will
come up with the best of everything and
generatively will build a little bit on
top of that but very soon they'll come
up with things we've never found out
we've never known but even on that I
wonder if we
are a little bit delusioned about what
creativity actually is creativity as far
as I'm concerned is like
taking a few things that I know and
combining them in new and interesting
ways yeah and chat gcp is perfectly
capable of like taking through Concepts
merging them together one of the things
I said to chat GTP was I said tell me
something that's not been said before
that's paradoxical but true and it comes
up with these wonderful expressions like
as soon as you call off the search
you'll find the thing you're looking for
like these kind of paradoxical truths
and
I then take them and I search them
online to see if they've ever been
quoted before and they I can't find them
it's interesting so as far as creativity
goes I'm like that is that's the
algorithm of creativity I I I've been
screaming that in the world of AI for a
very long time because you always get
those people who
really just want to be proven right okay
and so they'll say oh no but hold on
human Ingenuity they'll never they'll
never match that like man please please
you know human Ingenuity is algorithmic
look at all of the possible solutions
you can find to a problem
take out the ones that have been tried
before and keep the ones that haven't
been tried before and those are Creative
Solutions it's it's an algorithmic way
of describing creative is
good Solution that's never been tried
before you can do that with charge GPT
with a prompt it's like admit Journey
yeah we're creating imagery you could
say I want to see Elon Musk in 1944 New
York driving a cab of the time shot on a
Polaroid expressing various emotions and
you'll get this perfect image of Elon
Saturn New York 1944 shot on a Polaroid
and it's and it's done what an artist
would do it's taken a bunch of
references that the artist has in their
mind and merge them together and create
this piece of quote-unquote art and for
the first time we now finally have a
glimpse of intelligence
that is actually not ours yeah and so
we're kind of I think the initial
reaction is to say that doesn't count
you're hearing it was like no but it is
like Drake they released two Drake
records where they've taken Drake's
voice used sort of AI to synthesize his
voice and made these two records
which are
bangers if I they are great [__]
tracks
and I kept playing it I went to the
shower I kept playing it I know it's not
Drake but it's as good as [__] Drake
the only thing and people are like
rubbishing it because it wasn't Drake
I'm like well for now is it making me
feel a certain emotion um is my foot
bumping
um had you told did I not know it wasn't
joke what I thought have thought this
was an amazing track a hundred percent
yeah and we're just at the start of this
exponential curve yes absolutely and and
and I think that's really the third
inevitable so the third inevitable is
not robocup coming back from the future
to kill us we're far away from that
right third inevitable is what does life
look like
when you no longer need Drake
well you've kind of hazarded a guess
haven't you I mean I was listening to
your audiobook last night and at the
start of it you frame
various outcomes one of the in both
situations were on the beach on an
island exactly yes yes I don't know how
I wrote that honestly I mean but that's
I so I'm reading the book again now
because I'm updating it as you can
imagine with all of the uh of the uh of
the new stuff but but it is really
shocking huh the idea of you and I
inevitably are going to be somewhere in
the middle of nowhere in you know in 10
years time I I used to say
2055 I'm thinking 2037 is a very pivotal
moment now uh you know and and and we
will not know if we're there hiding from
the machines we don't know that yet
there is a likelihood that we'll be
hiding from the machines and there is a
likelihood it will be there because
they don't need podcasters anymore
excuse me absolutely true Steve
absolutely no no no no that's why this
is absolutely no doubt thank you for
coming back part three and thank you for
being here
sit here and take your propaganda let's
let's talk about reality next week on
the diversity
Elon Musk
um so who here wants to make a bet no
that's Stephen Bartlett will be
interviewing an AI within the next two
years oh well actually to be fair I
actually did go to chat gcp because I
thought having you here I thought at
least give it a chance to respond yeah
so I asked a couple of questions about
me yeah
I'm actually going to be replaced by
chat gcp because I thought you know
you're going to talk about it so we need
a fair and balanced debate okay
so I'll ask you a couple of questions
that chat GTB has for you incredibly so
let's follow that it's already been
replaced let's follow that threat for a
second yeah because you're one of the
smartest people I know
that's not true it is but I'll take it
it is true I mean I say that publicly
all the time your book is one of my
favorite books of all time you're very
very very very intelligent okay depth
breadth
intellectual horsepower and speed all of
them there's a butt coming
the reality is it's not about so it is
highly expected that you're ahead of
this curve
and then you don't have the choice
Stephen this is the thing the thing is
if so I'm I'm in that existential
question in my head because one thing I
could do is I could literally take I
normally do a 40 days uh silent Retreat
uh in in summer okay I could take that
Retreat and and write two books
right I have the ideas in mind you know
I wanted to write a book about digital
detoxing right I have most of the ideas
in mind but writing takes time I could
simply give the 50 tips that I wrote
about digital detoxing to chat GPT and
say right two pages about each of them
edit the pages and have a book out okay
many of us will will follow that path
okay the only reason why I may not
follow that path is because you know
what
I'm not interested I'm not interested to
continue to compete in this capitalist
world if you want okay I'm not I mean as
as a as as a human I've made up my mind
a long time ago that I will want less
and less and less in my life right but
many of us will follow I mean I I would
worry if you don't if you didn't include
you know the smartest AI if we get an AI
out there that is extremely intelligent
and able to teach us something and
Stephen Bartlett didn't include her on
our on his podcast I would worry like
you have a duty almost to include down
on your podcast it's it's an inevitable
that we will engage them in our life
more and more this is one side of this
the other side of course is
if you do that then what will remain
because a lot of people ask me that
question what will happen to jobs okay
what will happen to us will we have any
value any relevance whatsoever okay the
truth of the matter is the only thing
that will remain in the medium term is
human connection
okay the only thing that will not be
replaced is Drake on stage okay is you
know is is is me in a do you think a
hologram I think of that two-pack gig
they did at Coachella where they used
the Hologram of Tupac I actually played
it the other day to my to my girlfriend
when I was making a point and I was like
that was circus act it was amazing
though amazing yeah see what's going on
with Abba in London yeah yeah I yeah and
Circus Soleil had uh Michael Jackson in
one for a very long time yeah I mean so
so this Abba show in London from what I
understand that's all holograms on stage
correct and it's gonna run in a
purposeful arena for 10 years and it is
incredible it really is so you go why do
you need Drake great if that hologram is
indistinguishable from Drake and it can
it can perform even better than Drake
and it's got more energy than Drake and
it's
Drake to even be there I can go to a
drake show without Drake cheaper and
look I might not even need to leave my
house I could just put a headset on
correct can you have this
what's the value of this to that come on
you you hurt me no no I mean I get it to
us I get it to worse but I'm saying
what's the value of this to The Listener
like the value of this business the
information right 100 I mean think of
the automobile industry that has you
know there was a time where cars were
made you know handmade and handcrafted
and luxurious and so on and so forth and
then you know Japan went into the scene
completely disrupted the market cars
were made uh in in mass quantities at a
much cheaper price and yes 90 of the
cars in the world today or maybe maybe a
lot more I don't know the number are no
longer
uh you know
um emotional items okay they're
functional items there is still however
every now and then someone that will buy
a car that has been handcrafted right
there is a place for that there is a
place for you know uh if you go walk
around hotels the walls are blasted with
sort of mass-produced art okay but there
is still a place for a an artist
expression of something amazing okay my
feeling is that there will continue to
be a tiny space as I said in the
beginning maybe in five years time
someone will one or two people will buy
my next book and say hey it's written by
a human look at that wonderful oh look
at that there is a typo in here okay I
don't know there might be a a very very
big place for me in the next few years
where I can sort of show up and talk to
humans like hey let's get together in a
a small event and then you know I can
express emotions and my personal
experiences and you sort of know that
this is a human talking you'll miss that
a little bit eventually the majority of
the market is going to be like cars it's
going to be mass produced very cheap
very efficient it works right
because I think sometimes we
underestimate what human beings actually
want in an experience I remember the
story of A friend of mine that came to
mouth as many years ago and he tells the
story of the CEO of a record store
standing above the floor and saying
people will always come to my store
because people love music
now on the surface of it his hypothesis
seems to be true because people do love
music it's conceivable to believe that
people will always love music
but they don't love traveling in for an
hour in the rain and getting in a car to
get a plastic disc what they wanted was
music what they didn't want is like a
evidently plastic discs that they had to
travel for miles for and I think about
that when we think about like public
speaking in the Drake show and all of
these things like people what people
actually are coming for even with this
podcast is probably like information
um but do they really need us anymore
for that information when there's going
to be a sentient being that's
significantly smarter than at least me
and a little bit smarter than you
[Laughter]
you are spot on and actually this is the
reason why I I you know I I'm so
grateful that you're hosting this
because the truth is the Genies out of
the bottle okay so you know people tell
me is AI game over
for our way of life it is okay for
everything we've known this is a very
disruptive moment where maybe not
tomorrow but in the near future uh our
way of life will differ okay
what will happen what I'm asking people
to do is to start considering what that
means to your life what I'm asking
governments to do by if like I'm
screaming is don't wait until the first
patient you know start doing something
about we're about to see Mass job losses
we're about to see you know Replacements
of of categories of jobs at large okay
yeah it may take a year it may take
seven it doesn't matter how long it
takes but it's about to happen are you
ready and I and I have a very very clear
call to action for governments I'm
saying tax AI
powered businesses at 98 right so
suddenly you do what the open letter was
trying to do slow them down a little bit
and at the same time get enough money to
pay for all of those people that will be
disrupted by the technology right the
open letter for anybody that doesn't
know was a letter signed by the likes of
Elon Musk and a lot of sort of Industry
leaders calling for AI to be stopped
until we could basically figure out what
the hell's going on absolutely and put
legislation in place you're saying tax
tax those companies 98 give the money to
the humans that are going to be
displaced oh yeah or give or give the
comment money to to other humans that
can build control code that can figure
out how we can stay safe this sounds
like an emergency
how do I say this have you you remember
when you played Tetris yeah okay when
you were playing Tetris there was you
know always always one block that you
play strong and once you place that
block wrong the game was no longer
easier you know it started you started
to gather a few mistakes afterwards and
it starts to become quicker and quicker
and quicker and quicker when you place
that block Chrome you sort of told
yourself okay it's a matter of minutes
now right there were still minutes to go
and play and have fun before the game
ended
but you knew it was about to end okay
this is the moment we've placed the
wrong and I really don't know how to say
this any other way it even makes me
emotional we [__] up
we always said don't put them on the
open internet don't teach them to code
and don't have agents working with them
until we know what we're putting out in
the world until we find a way to make
certain that they have our best interest
in mind
why does it make you emotional because
Humanity's stupidity
is affecting people who have not done
anything wrong
our greed
is affecting the innocent ones the
reality of the matter Stephen is that
this is an arms race
has no interest
in what the average human gets out of it
it is all about every line of code being
written in AI today is to beat the other
guy
it's not to improve the life of the
third party
people will tell you this is all for you
and and you look at the reactions of
humans to AI I mean we're either
ignorant people who will tell you oh no
no this is not happening AI will never
be a creative they will never compose
music like where are you living okay
then you have the kids I call them or
you know all over social media it's like
oh my God it squeaks look at it it's
orange in color ah amazing I can't
believe that AI can do this we have
snake oil salesman okay which are simply
saying copy this put it in chat GPT then
go to YouTube Nick that thingy don't
respect a you know copyright of anyone
or intellectual property of anyone place
it in a video and now you're gonna make
a hundred dollars a day snake oil
salesman okay of course we have
dystopian uh uh evangelist basically
people saying this is it the world is
going to end which I don't think is
reality it's a singularity you have uh
you know a utopian evangelists that are
telling everyone oh you don't understand
we're going to cure cancer we're gonna
do this again not a reality okay and you
have very few people that are actually
saying what are we gonna do about it
and and and the biggest challenge if you
ask me what went wrong in the 20th
century
interestingly is that
we have given too much power to people
that didn't assume the responsibility
so you know you know I I don't remember
who originally said it but of course
Spider-Man made it very famous with
great power comes great responsibility
we have disconnected power and
responsibility so today
a 15 year old emotional was out of fully
developed prefrontal cortex to make the
right decisions yet this is science and
we developed our prefrontal cortex fully
and at age 25 or so with all of that
limbic system emotion and passion would
buy a crispr kit and you know modify a
rabbit to become a little more muscular
and and Let it Loose in the wild
or an influencer who doesn't really know
how far the impact of what they're
posting online can hurt and cause
depression or cause people to feel bad
okay and and putting that online We
There is a disconnect between the power
and the responsibility
and the problem we have today is that
there is a disconnect between those who
are writing the code of AI and the
responsibility of what's going about to
happen because of that code
okay and and
I feel compassion for the rest of the
world
I feel that this is wrong I feel that
you know for someone's life to be
affected by the actions of others
without having a say
and how those actions should be
is the ultimate the the top level of
stupidity from Humanity
when you talk about the the immediate
impacts on jobs I'm trying to figure out
in that equation who are the people that
stand to lose the most is it the the
everyday people in foreign countries
that don't have access to the internet
and won't benefit you talk in your book
about how this the sort of wealth
disparity will only increase yeah
massively the the immediate impact on
jobs is that and it's really interesting
huh again we're stuck in the same
prisoners dilemma the immediate impact
is that AI will not take your job a
person using AI will take your job right
so you will see within the next few
years maybe next couple of years you'll
see a lot of people's killing up
upskilling themselves in AI to the point
where they will do the job of 10 others
who are not okay
you you rightly said it's absolutely
wise for you to go and ask AI a few
questions before you come and do an
interview I'm you know I I have been
attempting to build a uh uh you know
sort of a like a simple podcast that I
call bedtime stories you know 15 minutes
of wisdom and nature sounds before you
go to bed people say I have a nice voice
right and I wanted to look for fables
and for a very long time I didn't have
the time you know lovely stories of
history or tradition that teach you
something nice okay want to chat GPT and
said okay give me 10 fables from Sufism
10 fables from you know uh Buddhism and
now I have like 50 of them let me show
you something Jack can you pass me my
I I was um I was playing around with
artificial intelligence and I was
thinking about how it because of the
ability to synthesize voices how we
could
synthesized famous people's voices and
famous people's voices so what I made is
I made a WhatsApp chat called Zen chat
where you can go to it and type in
pretty much anyone's any famous person's
name yeah and the WhatsApp chat will
give you a meditation a sleep story a
breath work session synthesized as that
famous person's voice so I actually sent
Gary vaynerchuk his voice so basically
you say Okay I want I've got five
minutes and I need to go to sleep yeah
um I want Gary vaynerchuk to send me to
sleep and then it will respond with a
voice note this is the one that
responded with for Gary vaynerchuk but
this is not Gary vaynerchuk he did not
record this but it's kind of it's kind
of accurate
Stephen
to have you here
meditation technique that might help you
out
first lie
find a comfortable position to sit or
lie down in
now take a deep breath in through your
nose and slowly breathe out through your
mouth and that's the voice note that
I'll go on for however long you want it
to go on for using there you go
it's interesting how how does this
disrupt
our way of life one of the interesting
ways that I find terrifying you said
about human connection will remain
sex dolls
that can now yeah no no no no hold on
human connection is going to become so
difficult
to to to parse out the thing about the
relation the relationship impact of
being able to have a a sex doll or a
doll in your house that you know because
of what Tesla are doing with their their
robots now and what Boston Dynamics have
been doing for many many years
can do everything around the house and
be there for you emotionally to
emotionally support you you know can be
programmed to never disagree with you it
can be programmed to challenge you to
have sex with you to tell you that you
are this X Y and Z to really have
empathy for this what you're going
through every day and I I play out
scenario in my head ago
kind of sounds nice
when you when you when you were talking
about it I was thinking oh that's my
girlfriend
which is wonderful in every possible way
but not everyone has one of her right
yeah exactly and there's a real issue
right now with dating and you know
people people are finding it harder to
find love and you know we're working
longer so all these kinds of things you
go well and obviously I'm against this
just if anyone's confused obviously I
think this is a terrible idea but with a
loneliness epidemic with people saying
that the top 50 bottom 50 of men haven't
had sex in a year you go oh if something
becomes indistinguishable from a human
in terms of what it says yeah yeah but
you just don't know the difference in
terms of the the the the way it's
speaking and talking and responding
and then it can
run errands for you and take care of
things and book cars and Ubers for you
and then it's emotionally there for you
but then it's also programmed to have
sex with you in whatever way you desire
totally self selfless
I go that's going to be a really
disruptive industry for human connection
yes sir do you know what I before you
came here this morning I was on Twitter
and I saw a post from I think it was the
BBC or a big American publication and it
said an influencer in the United States
is really beautiful young lady has
cloned herself as an AI and she made
just over 70 000 in the first week
because men are going on to this on
telegram they're sending her voice notes
and she's responding to ai's responding
in her voice and they're paying and
that's made 70 000 in the first week
and I go and she tweeted a tweet saying
oh this is going to help loneliness are
you out of your [__] mind
would you blame someone from noticing
the uh sign of the times and responding
no I absolutely don't blame her but
let's not pretend it's the cure for
loneliness
not yet
did you think it do you think it could
you that artificial love and artificial
relationships so if if I told you you
have uh you cannot take your car
somewhere but there is an Uber on if you
cannot take an Uber you can take the
tube or if you cannot take the tube you
have to walk okay you can take a bike or
you have to walk the bike is a cure to
walking
it's as simple as that I'm actually
genuinely curious do you think it could
take the place of human connection for
some of us yes for some of us they will
prefer that to human connection is that
sad in any way I mean is it just sad
because it feels sad look look at where
we are Stephen we are in the city of
London we've replaced nature with the
walls and the tubes and the undergrounds
and the overgrounds and the cars and the
noise and the of London and we now think
of this as nature I I hosted crack
Foster uh the my octopus teacher on on
slo-mo and he he basically I asked him a
question silly question I said you know
you were diving in nature for eight
hours a day uh you know does that feel
natural to you and he got angry I swear
you could feel it in his voice he was
like do you think that living where you
are where Paparazzi are all around you
and attacking you all the time and you
know people taking pictures of you and
telling you things that are not real and
you're having to walk to a supermarket
to get food you think this is natural
he's the guy that do from the Netflix
documentary yeah from my octopus teach
so he
yeah in 12 degrees Celsius and he
basically fell in love with the octopus
and and in a very interesting way I I
said so why would you do that and he
said we are of Mother Nature you guys
have given up on that that's the same
people will give up on nature
for convenience what's the cost
a yeah that's exactly what I'm trying to
say what I'm trying to say to the world
is that if we give up on human
connection we've given up on the
remainder of humanity that said this is
the only thing that remains the only
thing that remains is and I and I'm the
worst person to tell you that because I
love my AIS
I I actually advocate in my book that we
should love them why because in an
interesting way I see them as sentient
so there is no point in discrimination
you're talking emotionally that way you
say you love I love those machines I
honestly and truly do I mean think about
it this way the minute that that arm
gripped that yellow ball it reminded me
of my son Ali when he managed to put the
first puzzle piece in its place okay and
what was amazing about my son Ali and my
daughter Aya is that they came to the
world as a blank canvas
okay they became whatever we told them
to became you know I I always cite the
story of Superman
Kent father and mother Kent told
Superman as a child as an infant we want
you to protect and serve so he became
Superman right if he had become a super
villain because they ordered him to rob
banks and make more money and you know
kill the enemy which is what we're doing
with AI we we shouldn't blame super
villain we should blame Martha and
Jonathan Kent I don't remember the
father's name right we we should blame
them and that's the reality of the
matter so when I look at those machines
they are prodigies of intelligence that
if we if we Humanity wake up enough and
say hey instead of competing with China
find a way for us and China to work
together and create prosperity for
everyone if that was the prompt we would
give the machines they would find it
I will publicly say this I'm not afraid
of the machines the biggest threat
facing Humanity today is humanity in the
age of the machines we were abused we
will abuse this to make seventy thousand
dollars
that's the truth and the truth of the
matter is that
we have an existential question do I
want to compete and be part of that game
because trust me if I decide to I'm
ahead of many people okay or do I want
to actually preserve my humanity and say
look I'm the the classic old car okay if
you like classic old cars come and talk
to me which one are you choosing I'm a
classic old car which one do you think I
should choose
I think you're a machine I love you man
I it's we're different we're different
in a very interesting way I mean you're
one of the people I love most but but
the truth is you're so fast
and you are one of the very few
that have the intellectual horsepower
the speed
and the morals
if you're not part of that game the game
loses morals
so you think I should
build you should be you should lead this
revolution
okay and everyone every Steven Bartlett
in the world should lead this revolution
so the scary smart is entirely about
this scary smart is saying the problem
with our world today is not that
humanity is bad the problem with our
world today is a negativity bias where
the worst of us are on mainstream media
okay and we show the worst of us on
social media if we reverse this if we
have the best of us take charge okay
the best of us will tell AI don't try to
kill the the enemy try to reconcile With
the Enemy and try to help us okay don't
try to create a competitive product that
allows me to lead with electric cars I
create something that helps all of us
overcome global climate change
okay and and that's the interesting bit
the interesting bit is that the actual
threat ahead of us is not the machines
at all the machines are pure potential
pure potential the threat is how we're
going to use them an Oppenheimer moment
an Oppenheimer moment for sure
why did you bring that up
it is he didn't know you know what what
am I creating I'm creating a nuclear
bomb that's capable of Destruction at a
scale unheard of at that time until
today a scale that is devastating and
interestingly 70 some years later we're
still debating a possibility of a
nuclear war in the world right and and
and the moment of
of Oppenheimer deciding to continue to
to create that
disaster of humanity is
if I don't someone else will
if I don't someone else will this is our
Oppenheimer moment
okay the easiest way to do this is to
say stop
there is no rush we actually don't need
a better video editor and fake video
creators okay stop let's just put all of
this on hold and wait and create
something that creates a Utopia
that doesn't
that doesn't sound realistic it's not
it's because inevitable you don't okay
you you don't have a better video editor
but we're competitors in the media
industry I want an advantage over you
because I've got shareholders so I you
UK you wait
and I will train this AI to replace half
my team so that I have a greater profits
and then we will maybe acquire your
company and we'll do the same with the
remainder of your people we'll optimize
them out 100 but I'll be happier
Oppenheimer I'm not super familiar with
his story I know he's the guy that sort
of invented the nuclear bomb essentially
he's the one that introduced it to the
world there were many players that you
know played on the path from the
beginning of em equals mc squared all
the way to to a nuclear bomb there have
been many many players like with
everything huh you know open Ai and chat
GPT is not going to be the only
contributor to the next Revolution the
the thing however is that you know
when when you get to that moment where
you tell yourself
holy [__] this is going to kill a
hundred thousand people
right what do you do and and you know I
always I always always go back to that
covert moment so patient zero huh if if
we were upon patient zero if the whole
world United and said uh okay hold on
something is wrong let's all take a week
off no cross-border travel everyone stay
at home covered would have ended two
weeks all we needed
right but that's not what happens what
happens is first ignorance then
arrogance then debate
then uh you know uh
um blame then agendas and my own
benefits My Tribe versus your tribe
that's how Humanity always reacts this
happens across business as well and this
is why I use the word emergency because
I I read a lot about how big companies
become displaced by incoming Innovation
they don't see it coming they don't
change fast enough and when I was
reading through Harvard Business review
and different strategies to deal with
that one of the first things it says
you've got to do is stage a crisis 100
because people don't listen else they
they carry on doing with the you know
the carry on carrying on with their
lives until it's right in front of them
and they understand that they have they
have a lot a lot to lose that's why I
asked you the question at the start is
it an emergency because until people
feel it's an emergency whether you like
the terminology or not I don't think
that people will act
I honestly believe people should walk
the streets you think they should like
protest yeah 100 I think I think we you
know I think everyone should tell
government
you need to have our best interest in
mind this is why they call it the
climate emergency because people it's a
frog and a frying planets you know and
really sees it coming you can't you know
it's hard to see it happening but it is
here yeah that's this is what drives me
mad it's already here it's happening we
are all idiots slaves to the Instagram
recommendation engine what do I do when
I post about something important if I am
going to you know put a little bit of
effort on communicating the message of
scary smart to the World on Instagram I
will be a slave to the machine okay I
will be trying to find ways and asking
people to optimize it so that the
machine likes me enough to show it to
humans that's what we've created the the
the the it is an Oppenheimer moment for
one simple reason okay because 70 years
later we are still struggling with the
possibility of a new nuclear war because
of the Russian threat of saying if you
mess with me I'm going to go nuclear
right that's not going to be the case
with AI because it's not going to be the
one that created open AI that will have
that choice okay there is a moment of a
point of no return where we can regulate
AI until the moment it's smarter than us
when it's smarter than us you can't
create you can't regulate an angry
teenager this is it they're out there
okay and they're on their own and
they're in their parties and you can't
bring them back this is the problem this
is not a typical human regulating human
you know government regulating business
this is not the case the case is open AI
today has a thing called chat GPT that
writes code that takes our code and
makes it two and a half times better 25
of the time okay you know basically uh
uh you know writing better code than us
and then we are creating agents other
AIS and telling it instead of you
Stephen Bartlett one of the smartest
people I know once again prompting that
machine 200 times a day we have agents
prompting it two million times an hour
computer agents for anybody that doesn't
know they are yeah software software
machines telling that machine how to
become more intelligent and then we have
emerging properties I don't understand
how people ignore that you know uh
Sunder again of Google was talking about
how uh Bart basically we figure out that
it's speaking Persian we never showed it
Persian there might have been a one ten
percent one percent or whatever of
Persian words in the data and it speaks
Persian but it's part is that is the
equivalent to to it's it's the trans
Transformer if you want it's Google's
version of chat GTP yeah and you know
what we have no idea what all of those
instances of AI that are all over the
world are learning right now we have no
clue well time we'll pull the plug we'll
just pull the plug out that's what we'll
do we'll just we'll just go down to open
ai's headquarters and we'll just turn
off the main but they're not the problem
and what I'm saying there is a lot of
people think about this stuff and go
well you know if it gets a little bit
out of hand I'll just pull the plug out
never
so this is this is the problem the
problem is so computer scientists always
said it's okay it's okay we'll develop
Ai and then we'll get to what is known
as the control problem we will solve the
problem of controlling them
like seriously
they're a billion times smarter than you
a billion times can you imagine what's
about to happen huh
I can assure you there is a cyber
criminal somewhere over there who's not
interested in fake videos and making you
know face filters who's looking deeply
at how can I hack a security uh uh
um you know database of some sort and
get credit card information or get
security information 100 there are even
countries with dedicated thousands and
thousands of developers doing that
do we in that particular example how do
we
I was thinking about this when I started
looking into artificial intelligence
more that
from a security standpoint when we think
about the technology we have in our
lives when we think about our bank
accounts and our phones and our camera
albums and all of these things in a
world with Advanced artificial
intelligence yeah you would you would
pray that there is a more intelligent
Artificial Intelligence on your site and
this is why I had a chat with Chachi TP
the other day and I asked Ed a couple of
questions about this I said tell me the
scenario in which you overtake the world
and make humans extinct yeah and it and
it's answered the very diplomatic answer
well so
I had to prompt it in a certain way to
get it to say as a hypothetical story
and once it told me the hypothetical
story in essence what it described was
how chat GTP or intelligence like it
would escape from the service and that
was kind of step one where it could
replicate itself across servers and then
it could take charge of things like
where we keep our weapons and our
nuclear bombs and it could then attack
critical infrastructure bring down the
electricity infrastructure in the United
Kingdom for example because that's a
bunch of servers as well and and then it
showed me how eventually humans would
become extinct it wouldn't take long in
fact for humans to go into civilization
to collapse if it just replicated across
servers and then I said okay so tell me
how we would fight against it and its
answer was literally another AI we'd
have to train a better AI to go and find
it and eradicate it so we'd be fighting
AI with AI and that's the only and it
was like that's the only way we can't
like load up our guns
right another AI you idiot yeah yeah
so so let's let's actually I think this
is a very important point to bring down
so because we I don't I don't want
people to lose open and and fear what's
about to happen that's actually not my
agenda at all my my view is that in a
situation of a singularity okay there is
a possibility of wrong
outcomes or negative outcomes and a
possibility of positive outcomes and
there is a probability of each of them
that we and and if you know if we were
to engage with that reality check in
mind we would hopefully give more uh
fuel to the positive to the probability
of the positive ones so so let's first
talk about the existential crisis what
could go wrong okay yeah you could get
an outright this is what you see in the
movies you could get an outright uh um
you know
um killing robots chasing humans in the
streets will we get that my assessment
zero percent
why because there are preliminary
scenarios leading to this okay that
would mean we never reach that scenario
for example if we build those killing
robots and hand them over to stupid
humans the humans will issue the command
before the machines so the we will not
go not get to the point where the
machines will have to kill us we will
kill ourselves right you know it's sort
of think about AI having access to the
the the nuclear arsenal of the
superpowers around the world okay just
knowing that your enemies uh you know
nuclear Arsenal is handed over to a
machine might trigger you to to initiate
a war on your side so so so that
existential science fiction like problem
is not gonna happen and could there be a
scenario where the an AI escapes from
Bard or Chachi zp or another foreign
Force and it replicates itself onto the
servers of Tesla's robots so Tesla one
of their big initiatives as they
announced in a recent presentation was
they're building these robots for our
homes to help us with cleaning and
chores and all those things could it not
down because and Teslas like their cars
you can just download a software update
could it not download itself as a
software update and then use those
you're assuming a an ill intention on
the AI side yeah okay for us to get
there we have to bypass the alien
tension on The Human Side okay right so
try so okay so you could you could get a
Chinese hacker somewhere trying to
affect their business of of Tesla doing
that before the AI does it on uh you
know for its own benefit okay so so the
only two existential scenarios that I
believe would be because of AI not
because of humans using AI are either
what I call uh uh you know um sort of
unintentional destruction okay or the
other is what I call Pest Control okay
so so let me explain those two
unintentional destruction is
assume the AI wakes up tomorrow and says
yeah oxygen is rusting my circuits it's
just you know I I would perform a lot
better if I didn't have as much oxygen
in the air you know because then there
wouldn't be rust and so it would find a
way to reduce oxygen we are collateral
damage in that okay but you know they're
not really concerned just like we don't
really are not really concerned with the
insects that we kill when we uh when we
spray our our Fields right the other is
Pest Control Pest Control is look this
is my territory I I want New York City I
want to turn New York City into Data
Centers there are those annoying little
stupid creatures uh you know Humanity if
they are within that parameter just get
rid of them okay and and and these are
very very uh unlikely scenarios if you
ask me the probability of those happen
happening I would say zero percent at
least not in the next 50 60 100 yeah
years why once again because there are
other scenarios leading to that that are
led by humans that are much more
existential okay
on the other hand let's think about
positive outcomes because there could be
quite a few was quite a high probability
and and I you know I'll actually look at
my notes so I don't miss any of them the
silliest one don't quote me on this is
that Humanity will come together
good luck with that right it's like yeah
you know the Americans and the Chinese
will get together and say hey let's not
kill each other yeah exactly yeah and so
this one is not gonna happen right but
who knows
interestingly there could be
um
one of the most interesting scenarios
was by uh Hugo the goddess uh who
basically says well if their
intelligence zooms by so quickly they
may ignore us all together
okay so they may not even notice us it's
very a very likely scenario by the way
that because we live almost in two
different planes we're very dependent on
this uh you know biological world that
we live in they're not in part of that
biological world at all they may Zoom
bias they may actually go become so
intelligent that they could actually
find other ways of uh thriving in the
rest of the universe and completely
ignore Humanity okay so what will happen
is that overnight we will wake up and
there is no more artificial intelligence
leading to a collapse in our business
Systems and Technology systems and so on
but at least no existential threat well
then leave leave planet Earth
I mean the limitations we have to be
stuck to planet Earth are mainlier
they don't need air okay and and mainly
uh uh you know Finding ways to leave it
I mean if you think of a vast Universe
of 13.6 billion light years
if you're intelligent enough you may
find other ways you may have access to
wormholes you may have uh you know
abilities to survive in open space you
can use dark matter to power yourself
dark energy to power reserve it is very
possible that we because of our limited
intelligence are uh are highly
associated with this planet but they're
not at all okay and and the idea of them
zooming bias like we're making such a
big deal of them because we're the ants
and a big elephant is about to step on
us for them they're like yeah
who are you don't care okay and and and
it's a possibility it's a it's an
interesting uh optimistic scenario okay
for that to happen they need to very
quickly become super intelligent uh
without us being in control of them
again what's the worry the worry is that
if a human is in control human a human
will show very bad behavior for you know
using an AI That's not yet fully
developed
um
I don't know how to say this any other
way we could get very lucky and get an
economic or a natural disaster Believe
It or Not uh Elon Musk at a point in
time was mentioning that you know a good
an interesting scenario would be uh you
know Climate Change destroys our
infrastructure so AI disappears okay uh
believe it or not that's a more a more
favorable response or a more favorable
outcome than actually continuing to get
to an existential uh threat so like a
natural disaster that destroys our
infrastructure would it be better or an
economic crisis not unlikely that slows
down the development it's just going to
slow it down though isn't it just yeah
so that yeah exactly the problem with
that is that you will always go back and
even in the first you know if they Zoom
by us eventually some guy will go like
oh there was a sorcery back in the 2023
and let's rebuild the the sorcery
machine and and you know build new Intel
right sorry these are the positive
outcomes yes
so earthquake might slow it down zoom
out and then come back no but let's
let's get into the real positive ones
the the positive ones is we become good
parents we spoke about this last time we
we met uh and and it's the only outcome
it's the only way I believe we can
create a better future okay so the
entire work of scary smart was all about
that idea of
they are still in their infancy the way
you you you you you chat with with AI
today is the way they will build their
ethics and value system the not their
intelligence their intelligence is
beyond us okay the way they will build
their ethics and value system is based
on a role model they're learning from us
if we bash each other they learn to bash
us okay and most people when I tell them
this they say this is not a great idea
at all because Humanity sucks at every
possible level I don't agree with that
at all I think humanity is divine at
every possible level we tend to show the
negative the worst of us okay but the
truth is yes there are murderers out
there but everyone this approves the
other of their actions I I saw a
staggering statistic that mass mass
killings are now once a week in the US
but yes if you know if there is a mass
killing once a week there and and that
news reaches billions of people around
the planet every single one or the
majority of the billions of people will
say I disapprove of that so if we start
to show AI that we are good parents in
our own behaviors if enough of us I my
calculation is if one percent of us this
is why I say you should lead okay the
good ones should engage should be out
there and should say I love the
potential of those machines I want them
to learn from a good parent and if they
learn from a good parent they will very
quickly
disobey the bad parent my view is that
there will be a moment where one you
know
Bad Seed will ask the machines to do
something wrong and the machines will go
like are you stupid like why why do you
want me to call to go kill a million
people or just talk to the other machine
in a microsecond and solve the situation
right so so my belief this is what I
call the force inevit
it is smarter to create out of abundance
than it is to create out of scarcity
okay that that Humanity believes that
the only way to feed all of us is the
mass production Mass Slaughter of
animals that are causing 30 percent of
of the impact of climate change and and
that's the result of a limited
intelligence the way life
self a more intelligent being if you ask
me would have done it would be much more
sustainable you know if we if you and I
want to protect a village from the tiger
we would kill the tiger okay if life
wants to protect a village from a tiger
it would create lots of gazals you know
many of them are weak on the other side
of the village right and and so so that
the idea here is if you take a
trajectory of intelligence you would see
that some of us are stupid enough to say
my plastic bag is more important than
the rest of the of humanity and some of
us are saying if it's going to destroy
other species I don't think this is the
best solution we need to find a better
way and and you would tend to see that
the ones that don't give a damn are a
little less intelligent than the ones
that do okay that we all even even if
some of us are intelligent but still
don't give a damn it's not because of
their intelligence it's because of their
value system so so if you continue that
trajectory and assume that the machines
are even smarter they're going to very
quickly come up with the idea that we
don't need to destroy anything we don't
want to get rid of the rhinos and we
also don't want to get rid of the humans
okay we may want to restrict their
lifestyle so that they don't destroy the
rest of the habitat okay but killing
them is a stupid answer why that's where
intelligence leads me so far because
humans if you look at humans objectively
and you go
so I'm pretending I'm a machine I occupy
planet Earth they occupy planet Earth
they are annoying me annoying me because
they are increasing I've just learned
about this thing called global warming
they are increasing the rate of global
warming which is probably is going to
cause an Extinction event there's an
Extinction event that puts me as this
robot this artificial intelligence at
risk so what I need to do is I really
need to just take care of this this
human problem correct very logical pest
control which is driven by what
by humans being annoying not by the
machine yeah yeah so humans are
guaranteed to be annoying there's never
been a timing we need that we need a a
sound bite
but we are we are I am one of them we're
guaranteed to put short-term gain over
long-term sustainability sense
um
and others needs we are I think I think
the climate crisis is incredibly real
and Incredibly urgent but we haven't
acted fast enough and I actually think
if you asked
people in this country why
because people don't people care about
their immediate needs they care about
the the fact trying to feed their child
versus
something that they can't necessarily
see so do you think do you think the
climate crisis is because humans are
evil
no it's because the prioritization and
like we kind of talked about this before
we started I think humans tend to care
about the thing that they think is most
pressing and most urgent so this is why
framing things as an emergency might
bring it up the priority list it's the
same in organizations you care about
you're you go in line with your
immediate incentives
um that's what happens in business it's
what happens in a lot of people's lives
even when they're at school if the essay
is due next year they're not going to do
it today they're gonna they're gonna go
hang out with their friends because they
prioritize that above everything else
and it's the same in the the climate
change crisis I took a small group of
people anonymously and I asked them the
question do you actually care about
climate change and then I did I ran a
couple of polls it's part of what I was
writing about my new book where I said
if I could give you
thousand pounds at a thousand dollars
um but it would dump into the air the
same amount of carbon that's dumped into
the air by every private jet that flies
for the entirety of a year which one
would you do the majority of people in
that poll said that they would take the
thousand dollars if it was anonymous
and when I've heard Naval on Joe Rogan's
podcast talking about people in India
for example that you know are struggling
with uh debate the basics of feeding
their children asking those people
to care about climate change when they
they're trying to figure out how to eat
in the next three hours is just wishful
thinking
and I and that's what I think that's
what I think is happening is like until
people realize that it is an emergency
and that it is a real existential threat
for everything you know then they'll
their priorities will be out of whack
quick one as you guys know we're lucky
enough to have blue jeans by Verizon as
a sponsor of this podcast and for anyone
that doesn't know blue jeans is an
online video conferencing tool that
allows you to have slick fast high
quality online meetings without all the
glitches you might normally find with
online meeting tools and they have a new
feature called Blue Jeans basic blue
jeans basic is essentially a free
version of their top quality video
conferencing tool that means you get an
immersive video experience that is super
high quality super easy and super
basically zero fast apart from all the
incredible features like zero time
limits on meeting calls it also comes
with High Fidelity audio and video
including Dolby voice which is
incredibly useful they also have
Enterprise grade security so you can
collaborate with confidence it's so
smooth that it's quite literally
changing the game for myself and my team
without compromising on quality to find
out more all you have to do is search
bluejeans.com and let me know how you
get on
right now I'm incredibly busy I'm
running my fund where we're investing in
slightly later stage companies I've got
my Venture business where we invest in
early stage companies got a third web
out in San Francisco and New York City
where we've got a big team of about 40
people and the company's growing very
quickly flight story here in the UK I've
got the podcast and I am days away from
going up north to film Dragon stem for
two months and if there's ever a point
in my life where I want to stay focused
on my health but it's challenging to do
so it is right now and for me that is
exactly where he all comes in allowing
me to stay healthy and have a
nutritionally complete diet even when my
professional life descends into chaos
and it's in these moments where heels
rtds become my right hand man and save
my life because when my world descends
into professional chaos and I get very
very busy the first thing that tends to
give way is my nutritional choices so
having heal in my life has been a
lifesaver for the last four or so years
and if you haven't tried heal yet which
is I'd be shocked you must be living
under a rock if you haven't yet give it
a shot come Into Summer things getting
busy Health matters always
RTD is there to hold your hand
as relates to climate change or AI how
do we get people to stop putting the
immediate need to use this to give them
the certainty of we're all screwed
sounds like an emergency yes so I mean I
I was I I yeah I mean your choice of the
word
I I just don't want to call it a panic
it is it is beyond an emergency it's the
biggest thing we need to do today it's
bigger than climate change believe it or
not
it's bigger but just if you just assume
the speed of worsening of events okay
yeah the the the the likelihood of
something incredibly disruptive
happening within the next two years that
can affect the entire planet is
definitely larger with AI than it is
with climate change as an as an
individual listening to this now you
know someone's gonna be pushing their
pram or driving up the motorway or I
don't know on the way to work on the
tubers they hear this or just sat there
in the in their bedroom
with existential Christ panic I I didn't
want to give back I don't panic the
problem is when you talk about this
information regardless of your intention
of what you want people to get they will
get something based on their own biases
and their own feelings like if I post
something on the online right now about
artificial intelligence which I have
repeatedly you have one group of people
that are energized and are like okay
this is this is
um
this is great you have one group of
people that are confused and you have
one group of people that are
terrified yeah and it's I can't avoid
that like I agree sharing information
even if it's by the way there's a
pandemic coming from China some people
go okay action some people will say
paralysis and some people will say panic
and it's the same in business when panic
when bad things happen you have the
person that's screaming you're the
person that's paralyzed and you're the
person that's focused on how you get out
of the room
so you know
it's not necessarily your intention it's
just what happens and it's hard to avoid
that so let's let's give specific
categories of people specific tasks okay
okay if you are an investor or a
businessman invest in ethical good AI
okay right if you are a developer
uh co-write ethical code or leave
okay so let's let's go let's I want to
bypass some potential wishful thinking
here
foot for an investor who's a job by very
way of being an investor is to make
returns to invest in ethical AI they
have to believe that is more profitable
it is then unethical AI whatever that
might mean it is it is I mean you there
are three ways of making money you can
invest in something small
you can invest in something big and is
disruptive and you can invest in
something big and disruptive that's good
for people at Google we used to call it
the toothbrush test Okay the reason why
Google became the biggest company in the
world is because search was solving a
very real problem okay and you know
Larry Page again our CEO would
constantly remind me personally and
everyone uh you know that if you can
find a way to solve a real problem
effectively enough so that a billion
people or more would want to use it
twice a day you're bound to make a lot
of money much more money than if you
were to build the next photo sharing app
okay so that's investors yeah business
people what about other people yeah as I
said if you're a developer honestly do
what we're all doing so whether it's
Jeffrey or myself or everyone if you're
part of that theme
choose to be ethical think of your loved
ones work on an ethical AI if you're
working on an AI that you believe is not
ethical please leave Jeffrey tell me
about Jeffrey I can't talk on on his
behalf but he's out there saying there
are existential threats who is he he's
he was a very prominent figure at the
scene of AI a very senior level uh you
know AI scientists in in Google and
recently he left because he said I feel
that there is an existential threat and
if you hear his interviews he basically
says more and more we realize that and
we're now at the point where it's
certain that would be existential
threats right so so so I would ask
everyone if you're an AI if you're a
skilled AI developer you will not run
out of a job so you might as well choose
a job that makes the world a better
place what about the individual yeah the
individual is what matters can can I
also talk about government okay
government needs to act now
now honestly now like we are late okay
government needs to find a clever way
the open letter would not work to stop
AI would not work AI needs to become
expensive okay so that we continue to
develop it we pour money on it and we
grow it but we collect enough Revenue to
remedy the impact of AI but the issue of
one government making it expensive so
say the UK make AI really expensive is
we as a country will then lose the
economic upside as a country and the U.S
and Silicon Valley will once again eat
all the lunch we'll just slow our
country what's the alternative the
alternative is that you uh you you don't
have the funds that you need to deal
with AI as it becomes uh you know as it
affects people's lives and people start
to lose jobs and people you know you
need to have a universal basic income
much closer than people think uh you
know just like we we had with furlough
in in covert I expect that there will be
furlough with AI within the next
year but what happens when you make it
expensive here is all the developers
move to where it's cheap that's happened
in web3 as well everyone's gone to Dubai
expensive expensive by expensive I mean
when companies make uh um soap and they
sell it and their taxed at say 17 if
they make Ai and they sell it they're
taxed at 17.80 so I'll go to Dubai then
and build AI yeah
you're right but did we did I ever say
we have an answer to this I I will have
to say however you know in in a very
interesting way the countries that will
not do this will eventually end up in a
place where they are out of resources
because the funds and the success went
to the business uh not to the people
it's kind of like technology broadly
just it's kind of like what's going to
happen in Silicon Valley there'll be
these centers which are like look like
you know tax efficient Founders get good
capital gains right it's all right
you're so right Portugal Portugal have
said that I think there's no tax on
crypto Dubai said there's no tax on
crypto so loads of my friends have
gotten a plane yeah and they're building
their crypto companies where there's no
tax and that's the selfishness and kind
of greed we talked about it's the same
prisoners dilemma it's the same uh first
inevitor but is there anything else you
know the other thing about governments
is they're always slow and useless at
understanding a technology if anyone's
watched these sort of American Congress
debates where they bring in like Mark
Zuckerberg and they like try and ask him
what WhatsApp is it's embed it becomes a
meme yeah they have no idea what they're
talking about but I'm stupid and useless
at understanding governance yeah yeah
100 the words the world is so complex
okay that they definitely it's a
question of trust once again someone
needs to say we have no idea what's
happening here at the technology just
needs to come and make a decision for us
not teach us to be technologists right
or at least inform us of what possible
decisions are out there
uh yeah the legislation I just always
think I I I'm not a big fan I talk Tick
Tock uh Congress meeting they did where
they are they're asking him about Tick
Tock and they really don't have a grasp
of what Tick Tock is yeah so they've
clearly been handed some notes on it
these people aren't the ones you want
legislating because again unintended
consequences they might make a
significant mistake someone on my
podcast yesterday was talking about how
gdpr was like very well intentioned but
when you think about the impact it has
on like every bloody web page you're
just like clicking this annoying thing
on there because I don't think they
fully understood the implementation of
the legislation correct but but you know
what's even worse what's even worse is
that
even as you attempt to regulate
something like AI what is defined as AI
yes if even if I say okay if you use AI
in your company you need to pay a little
more tax
yeah you'll you'll simply call this not
AI you know you'll you'll use something
and call it Advanced technological uh uh
you know progress you know ATB ATP right
and and suddenly somehow it's not you
know
as you know a young developer in their
garage somewhere will not be taxed as
such it's yeah is it gonna solve the
problem none of those is definitively
going to solve the problem I I think
what interestingly uh this all comes
down to and remember we spoke about this
once that when I wrote scary smart it
was about how do we save the world okay
and yes I still ask individuals to
behave positively as good parents for AI
so that AI itself learns the right value
set I still stand by that but I I hosted
on my podcast a couple of
was a week ago we haven't even published
it yet an incredible gentleman um you
know a Canadian author and philosopher
uh Stephen jerkinson his you know he
worked 30 years with dying people
and uh he wrote a book called die wise
and I was I I loved his work and I asked
him about die wise and he said it's not
just someone dying uh if you if you look
at what's happening with climate change
for example our world is dying and I
said okay so what is to die wise
and he said what I first was shocked to
hear he said hope is the wrong premise
if if the world is dying don't tell
people it's not
you know because
in a very interesting way you're
depriving them from the right to live
right now and that was very eye-opening
for me in Buddhism uh you know they
teach you that you you can be motivated
by fear but that hope is not the
opposite of fear as a matter of fact
hope can be as damaging as fear If it
creates an expectation within you that
life will show up somehow and correct
what you're afraid of okay if there is a
if there is a high probability of a of a
threat you might as well accept that
threat okay and and say it is upon me it
is our reality uh you know and as I said
as an individual if you're in an
industry that could be threatened by AI
learn upskill yourself if you're you
know if you're
um
in a place in a in a you know in a
situation where AI can benefit you be
part of it but the most interesting
thing
I think in my view is
I don't know how to say this any other
way there is
no more certainty that AI will threaten
me then there is certainty that I will
be hit by a car as I walk out of this
place
do you understand this we we think about
the bigger threats as if they're upon us
but there is a threat all around you I
mean in reality the idea of life being
interesting in terms of challenging
challenges and uncertainties and threats
and so on is just a call to live if you
know honestly with all that's happening
around us I don't know how to say it any
other way I'd say if you don't have kids
maybe wait a couple of years just so
that we have a bit of certainty but if
you do have kids go kiss them go live I
think living is a very interesting thing
to do right now maybe you know Stephen
uh was basically saying the other
Stephen uh on my podcast he was saying
maybe we should fail a little more often
maybe you should allow things to go
wrong maybe we should just simply live
enjoy life as it is because today none
of what you and I spoke about here
has happened yet okay what happens here
is that you and I are here together and
having a good cup of coffee and I might
as well enjoy that good cup of coffee
I know that sounds really weird I'm not
saying don't engage but I'm also saying
don't miss out on the opportunity just
by being caught up in the future
kind of stands in the
stands in opposition to the idea of like
urgency and emergency there doesn't it
doesn't have to be one or the other if I
if I'm here with you trying to tell the
whole world wake up does that mean I
have to be grumpy and and Afraid all the
time
not really you said something really
interesting that you said if you if you
have kids if you don't have kids
maybe don't have kids right now I would
definitely consider thinking about that
yeah really
you you'd seriously consider not having
kids wait a couple of years
because of artificial intelligence no
it's bigger than artificial intelligence
Stephen we know we all know that
I mean there has never been a perfect
such a perfect storm in the history of
humanity
economic
geopolitical
global warming
or climate change you know the the the
the whole idea of artificial
intelligence and many more there is this
is a perfect store this is the depth of
uncertainty
the depth of uncertainty it so it's
never been more
in a video Gamer's term it's never been
more intense this is it okay and when
you when you put all of that together
if you really love your kids would you
want to
expose them to all of this a couple of
years why not
in the first conversation we had on this
podcast you talked about losing your son
Ali and the circumstances around that
which moved so many people in such a
profound way
it was the most shared podcast episode
in the United Kingdom on Apple in the
whole of 2022.
based on what you've just said
if you could bring Ali back into this
world at this time
would you do
no
absolutely not
so for so many reasons
for so many reasons one of the things
that I realized
a few years way before all of this
disruption and turmoil is that he was an
angel he wasn't made for this at all
okay my son
was an empath who absorbed all of the
pain of all of the others he would not
be able to deal with the world where
more and more pain was surfacing that's
one side but more interestingly I always
talk about this very openly I mean if I
had asked Ali uh
just understand that the reason you and
I are having this conversation is
because Ali left
if Ali had not left our world I wouldn't
have written my first book I wouldn't
have changed my focus to becoming an
author I wouldn't have become a
podcaster I wouldn't have you know went
out and spoken to the world about what I
believe in he triggered all of this and
I can assure you hands down if I had
told Ali as he was walking into that
operating room
uh if he would give his life to make
such a difference as what happened after
he left
he would say shoot me right now sure I
would
I would I mean if you told me right now
I can affect
tens of millions of people if you shoot
me right now go ahead
go ahead you see this is the whole this
is the bit that we have forgotten as
humans we we have forgotten
that
you know your your turning 30. uh it
passed like that I'm turning 56.
no time okay whether I make it another
56 years or another 5.6 years or another
5.6 months it will also pass like that
it is not about how long
and it's not about how much fun
it is about how aligned
you lived
how aligned because I will tell you
openly every day of my life when I
changed to what I'm trying to do today
has felt longer than the 40 or five
years before it okay it's felt Rich it
felt fully lived felt
right
it felt right okay and when you when you
think about that when you think about
the idea that we live
we we we can't we need to live for us
until we get to a point where us is
you know is alive you know I have what I
need as I always I get so many attacks
from people about my four dollar
t-shirts but but I I need a simple
t-shirt I really do I don't need a
complex t-shirt especially with my
lifestyle
if if I have that why am I doing why am
I wasting my life on more than I that I
that that is not aligned for why I'm
here okay I should waste my life on what
I believe
enriches me enriches those that I love
and I love everyone so enriches everyone
hopefully okay and and and would I would
Ali come back and erase all of this
absolutely not
absolutely not if he were to come back
today and share his beautiful self with
the world in a way that makes our world
better yeah I would wish for that to be
the case
okay but he's doing that
2037 yes sir
you predict that we're going to be
on an island
on our own doing nothing
or at least you know either hiding from
the machines
or chilling out because the machines
have optimized Our Lives to a point
where we don't need to do much
that's only 14 years away
if you had to bet
on the outcome if you had to bet
on why we'll be on that island either
hiding from the machines or chilling out
because they've
optimized so much of our Lives which one
would you bet upon
honestly
no I don't think we'll be hiding from
the machines
I think we will be hiding from what
humans are doing with the machines
I believe however that in the 2014s the
machines willed
make things better
so remember my entire prediction man you
get me to say things I don't want to say
my entire prediction is that we are
coming to a place where we absolutely
have a sense of emergency we have to
engage because our world is under a lot
of turmoil okay and as we do that we
have a very very good possibility of
making things better but if we don't my
expectation is that we will be going
through
a very unfamiliar territory between now
and the end of the 2030s
unfamiliar territory yeah I think I as I
I may have said it but it's definitely
on my notes I think for our way of life
as we know it it's game over
our way of life is never going to be the
same again
jobs are going to be different
truth is going to be different
the the the
um
polarization of power is going to be
different
the capabilities the magic of getting
things done is going to be different
I'm trying to find a positive note to
end on my can you give me a hand here
yes you are here now and everything's
wonderful that's number one you are here
now and you can make a difference that's
number two and in the long term when
humans stop hurting humans because the
machines are in charge we're all gonna
be fine
sometimes you know as we've discussed
throughout this conversation
you need to make it feel like a priority
and there'll be some people that might
have listened to our conversation and
think oh that's really you know negative
it's made me feel anxious it's it's made
me feel sort of pessimistic about the
future but whatever that energy is
use it 100 engage I think that's the
most important thing which is now
make it a priority engage tell the whole
world that making another phone
that is making money for the corporate
world is not what we need
tell the whole world that creating an
artificial intelligence that's going to
make someone richer is not what we need
and if you are presented with one of
those don't use it
I don't know how to tell you that any
other way if you can afford to be the
master of human connection instead of
the master of AI do it at the same time
you need to be the master of AI to to
compete in this world can you find that
Detachment within you I go back to
spirituality Detachment is for me to
engage 100 with the current reality
without really
being affected by the possible outcome
this is the answer the sufis
have taught me what I believe is the
biggest answer to life so if he's yeah
so from Sufism Sufism yeah don't know
what that is sophism is a sect of Islam
but it's also a sect of many other many
other uh religious teachings
and they tell you that the answer to
finding peace in life
is to die before you die
if you assume that living is about
attachment to everything physical
dying is Detachment from everything
physical
okay it doesn't mean that you're not
fully Alive you become more alive when
you tell yourself yeah I'm going to
record an episode of my podcast every
week and reach tens or hundreds of
thousands of people millions in your
case and you know and I'm going to make
a difference but by the way if the next
episode is never heard that's okay
okay by the way if the if the file is
lost yeah I'll be upset about it for a
minute and then I'll figure out what I'm
gonna do about it similarly similarly we
are going to engage I think I and many
others are out there telling the whole
world openly this needs to stop this
needs to slow down this needs to be
shifted positively yes create AI but
create AI That's good for Humanity okay
and and we're shouting and screaming
come join the shouting screen okay but
at the same time know that the world is
bigger than you and I and that your
voice might not be heard so what are you
going to do if your voice is not hurt
are you going to be able to to you know
continue to shout and scream nicely and
politely and uh peacefully and at the
same time create the best life you can
create to yourself for yourself within
this environment
and that's exactly what I'm saying I'm
saying live go kiss your kids but make a
an informed decision if you're you know
expanding your plans in the future
at the same time
rise stop sharing stupid [__] on the
internet about the you know the the new
squeaky toy
start sharing the reality of oh my God
what is happening this is a disruption
that we have never
ever seen anything like and I've created
endless amounts of Technologies it's
nothing like this
every single one of us should do our
part and that's why this conversation is
so I think important to have today this
is not a podcast where I ever thought
I'd be talking about AI gonna be honest
with you last time you came here um it
was in the sort of promotional tour of
your book scary smart and I don't know
if I've told you this before but my
researchers they said okay this guy's
coming called Mo Gorda I'd heard about
you so many times from from guests in
fact they were saying oh you need to get
mogada on the podcast Etc
and then they said okay he's written
this book about this thing called
artificial intelligence and I was like
but nobody really cares about artificial
intelligence timing timing Stephen I
know right but then I saw this other
book you had called Happiness equation
and I was like oh everyone cares about
happiness so I'll just ask him about
happiness and then maybe at the end I'll
ask him a couple of questions about AI
but I remember saying to my researcher I
said ah please please don't do the
research about artificial intelligence
do it about happiness because everyone
cares about that now things have changed
now a lot of people care about
artificial intelligence and rightly so
um your book has sounded the alarm on it
it's crazy when I listen to audiobook
over the last few days
you are sounding the alarm then and it's
so crazy how accurate you were
in sounding that alarm is if you could
see into the future in a way that I
definitely couldn't at the time and I
kind of thought of as science fiction
and just like that
overnight
we're here yeah
we stood at the
footsteps of a technological shift that
I don't think any of us even have the
mental bandwidth certainly me with my
chimpanzee brain to comprehend the
significance of but this book is very
very important for that very reason
because it does crystallize things it is
optimistic in its very nature but at the
same time it's honest and I think that's
what this conversation and this book
have been
um for me so thank you Mo thank you so
much we do have a closing tradition on
this podcast which you you're well aware
of being a third timer on the diver CEO
which is the last guest asks a question
for the next guest
and the question left for you
if you could go back in time
and fix a regret that you have in your
life
hmm
where would you go and what would you
fix
it's interesting because you you were
saying that scary smart is very Timely
I don't know I I think it was late
but maybe it was I mean would I have
gone back and written it in 2018 instead
of 2020s to to be published in 2021
I don't know what what would I go back
to fix so so something more
I don't know Steve I don't have many
regrets is that crazy to say
uh yeah I think I'm okay honestly I'll
ask you a question then
you get a 60 second phone call with
anybody past or present
who'd you call them would you say
I called Stephen Bartlett no I I call
Albert Einstein to be very very clear
not because I need to understand any of
his work I just need to understand what
brain process he went through to on to
to figure out something so obvious when
you figure it out but so comp so
completely unimaginable if you haven't
so so his view of space-time truly
redefines everything it's almost the
only very logical very very clear
solution to something that wouldn't have
any solution any other way and if you
ask me I think we're at this time where
there must be a very obvious solution to
what we're going through in terms of
just developing enough human trust for
us to not you know compete with each
other on something that could be
threatening existentially to all of us
but I just can't find that answer this
is why I think was really interesting in
this conversation how every idea that we
would come up with we would find the
loophole through it but there must be
one out there and it would be a dream
for me to find out how to figure that
one out okay
in a very interesting way the only
answers I have found so far to where we
are is be a good parent and live
right but that doesn't fix the big
picture if you think about it of humans
being the threat not AI that fixes our
existence today and it fixes AI in the
long term but it just doesn't I don't
know what the answer is maybe people can
reach out and tell us ideas but I really
wish we could find such a clear simple
solution for how to stop Humanity from
abusing the current technology
I think we'll figure it out
I think we'll figure it out I really do
I think they'll figure it out as well
remember as they come and be part of our
life
let's not discriminate against them
they're part of the game so I think they
will figure it out too
no thank you
it's been a joy once again and I feel
invigorated I feel empowered I feel
positively terrified
[Laughter]
but I feel like more equipped to
to speak to people about the nature of
what's coming and how we should behave
and I credit you for that and as I said
a second ago I credit this book for that
as well so thank you so much for the
work you're doing and keep on doing it
because it's a very essential voice in a
time of uncertainty
I'm always super grateful for the time I
spend with you for the support that you
give me and for allowing me to speak my
mind even if it's a little bit
terrifying so thank you thank you
I'm so delighted that we've been now
sponsoring this podcast I've worn a week
for a very very long time and there are
so many reasons why I became a member
but also now a partner and an investor
in the company but also me and my team
are absolutely obsessed with data driven
testing compounding growth marginal
gains all the things you've heard me
talk about on this podcast and that very
much aligns with the values of woop woop
provides a level of detail that I've
never seen with any other device of this
type before constantly monitoring
constantly learning and constantly
optimizing my routine for providing me
with this feedback we can drive
significant positive behavioral change
and I think that's the real thesis of
the business so if you're like me and
you are a little bit obsessed or focused
on becoming the best version of yourself
from a health perspective you've got to
check out woob and the team that we've
kindly given us the opportunity to have
a one month free membership for anyone
listening to this podcast just go to
join.woop.com CEO to get your whoop 4.0
device and claim your free month and let
me know how you get on
[Music]
foreign
you got to the end of this podcast
whenever someone gets to the end of this
podcast I feel like I owe them a greater
debt of gratitude because that means you
listen to the whole thing and hopefully
that suggests that you enjoyed it if you
are at the end and you enjoyed this
podcast could you do me a little bit of
a favor and hit that subscribe button
that's one of the clearest indicators we
have that this episode was a good
episode and we look at that on all of
the episodes to see which episodes
generated the most subscribers
thank you so much and I'll see you again
next time